Hello. I'm Alice Oseman.
I'm the writer and creator
of Heartstopper.
Slate 1,000. Take one.
The show is a little bit
different to the comic
and I like to think of it
in that
the TV show is an expanded
version of the comic.
The core story of
Heartstopper is
very much in the show.
We haven't changed
what is in the comic.
We've just made
the story bigger.
We've made the world wider.
Beyond Nick and Charlie's
story,
we learn a lot more about
Tao and Elle
and Tara and Darcy.
And there are also
new characters as well.
The thing that I've learnt
about adaptations is that
something that works for
one format, like a comic,
might not work for
a TV show.
So, when developing
Heartstopper as a TV show,
we had to look at it
from a TV perspective
and think
how do we take this story
and make it work on screen?
And that's been part of
the fun of it for me,
just expanding the story
to make it
a really cool TV show.
Seeing the characters
for the first time was
so surreal.
It was probably
during rehearsals
when we first saw them
all together
in, like,
the Heartstopper gang
and it was just very weird.
You know,
they're all amazing
and it's just been
wonderful.
We're there
if they have any problems
or anything, you know, that
they want to talk about,
just anything to do with
the show.
I mean,
they're all so talented.
They just are
the characters.
We're just there
to support them
and see them thrive.
So, my day-to-day experience
on set,
because I've been here
every day…
Basically me and Patrick,
one of
the executive producers,
we watch all the scenes.
We talk to Euros,
the director.
We sort of share ideas about
how things should be filmed
and we're also
in consultation with
all the
different departments,
like costume and the
art department and props.
And I kind of feel like
it's my role to
represent the comic
and the readers
and I think that
we have achieved that.
So, I had never been on
a TV set before.
I honestly didn't know
anything about TV making
before this.
And I've just learnt so much
about
what everyone on set does,
all the different roles
that there are.
And it really is
a team effort, which is…
You know, I'm a writer.
I'm used to working
by myself.
But this has, you know,
really highlighted what
you can do when there are
so many different
talented people involved.
I want Heartstopper to
inspire young people,
especially
young LGBTQ+ people,
to be
whoever they want to be
and to believe that
they can find happiness
and find love
and find friendship.
Because it is
a joyful story,
everyone can get something
out of it, so…